alors notre vie de petit lait la
première attaque où on est c'est tout de
suite cet aspect là un peu sucré un peu
charmant du double cd r d le sheep
madeleine dufour décrit bel et bien la
rom d'une autre vie étant donné qu'on
ait une fromagerie qui généreront des
quantités assez importantes de petit
lait on se doit de gérer ses déchets le
la monarque pour nous on a trouvé le
plus simple c'est de le valoriser en
alcool et donc c'est pour ça que yann dû
tirer à côté d'une fromagerie
dans ce paysage enchanteur de charlevoix
on trouve de nombreuses fermes laitières
et des fromagers comme la famille
vigneron dont la réputation n'est plus à
faire
la fabrication du fromage produit
beaucoup de lactosérum communément
appelé le petit lait mais quand on parle
du l'air en fait le fromage devient la
partie solide puis il ya la partie
liquide qui reste à la fois le petit
lait qui laisse les sauces et
principalement de l'os et du lactose il
fait son petit numéro travers de tso
pratiquement il reste plus matière gorge
parce que d'autres protéines non plus
fait vraiment c'est de l'eau du lactose
avec un nutriment si on transforme sa
litres de lait baissé presque et 80 90
litres de petit lait qui vont sortir à
la fin donc sauf de voeux postaux des
chèques aux jets rhinois talent
fromagerie
au québec on produit plus de 200 mille
tonnes de fromage chaque année c'est
ainsi que plus de 1 million 200 mille
tonnes de petit lait doivent être
recyclées de plusieurs choses qui se
font il ya beaucoup d'industries qui
vont faire la peau de lait avec pour
déshydrater habituellement cette poudre
de lait est utilisé pour nourrir les
animaux d'élevage ou d'un transformation
alimentaire par exemple dans les
produits laitiers on la voit souvent
sous l'appellation substances laitières
modifié
on a appris que même en mongolie il y
avait des gens qui distillait du lait de
yack donc ça ça remonte à on pense il ya
énormément d'année parce que finalement
l'homme veut tout tout distillé un
pendant plus de deux ans les dufour ont
ainsi travaillé à développer une eau de
vie à base de petit lait le principe de
base la distillation c'est souvent
récupéré des matières qui ont peut-être
un peu moins de valeur certaines séries
doit avoir une matière première qui va
être végétales d'autres vont référé
avoir un fruit d'autres vos préférés à
bord une céréale par exemple et puis
dans notre coeur on s'est dit pourquoi
pas essayer de distinguer une petit lait
pour essayer d'en faire un nouveau
produit
une eau de vie c'est vraiment l'esprit
d'une fermentation dans notre coeur on
ne choisi l'appellation autre vie parce
que au départ on voulait choisir le mot
vodka rapidement on s'est fait dire soit
vous devez le dc encore plus pour aller
chercher de neutralité qui est vraiment
parfaite ou soit vous changez de nom
carrément puis vous l'appelez au devis
ou sperme et en anglais donc nous on
s'est dit la personnalité qui est à
l'intérieur de cet alcool est trop
agréable et trop magnifique donc on va
célébrer cette différence l'appui on va
l'appeler ou du 100% du petit lait de la
famille migneron est récupérée pour la
distillation
le principe de base d'économie
circulaire c'est de valoriser chaque
étape d'un cycle donc pour nous mais on
va transformer le lait on va donner la
plus belle des valeurs au lait qui à
notre avis est le fromage puis ensuite
de ce pays à un produit qui va s'écouler
qui est le petit lait pour produire une
bouteille d'autres vies on va avoir
besoin des proxys massivement 18 litres
de petit lait il faut avoir produit une
meule de fromage ça va prendre environ
25 litres de lait et pourquoi générer 25
litres de lait ça prend soin une vache
ou 9 brebis si on est capable de
récupérer le maximum de ce qu'on rejette
des je pense que c'est ça l'avenir aussi
c'est de laisser dans une culture qui
est durable aussi qui est plus verte qui
est consciente de ce conte de ce qu'on
me laisse derrière nous après chaque
procédé qui est dans notre cas c'est
vraiment c'est ce qu'ils bouclaient le
tout
la production d'alcool de petit lait en
est à ses balbutiements
on voit apparaître ce type d'autres vies
notamment en ontario et en oregon
c'est un alcool qui va avoir des notes
un petit peu de caramel mais aussi en
même temps de petits fruits dont on va
avoir un et deux bleus est né de petites
fraises deschamps on va voir un et
sucrées quand même qui revient qui va
être très charmant la deuxième rangée va
être vraiment sûr le bleu est sûre le
petit fruit qui va embarquer ce que je
remarque c'est le côté de l'acte et du
noni c'est comme sortir un peu du lait
sucré
c'est le fruit la petite nuance tu va le
remarquer avec un spiritueux à 40% comme
ça souvent on va avoir tendance avec les
bières et les vins ce qui est tout à
fait normal c'est de prendre notre
gorgée et d'oxygène et la bouche alors
que dans les spiritueux mais si on
oxygène c'est là que l'effet de brûlures
arrive puis ça vient masquer les vrais
parfum puisque les gens suggérant
dégustation de spiritueux c'est de
prendre une petite gorgée et de venir
réchauffer la bouche l'élève fermé parce
que c'est ce qui va faire en sorte que
les vapeurs rsa l'intérieur puis qu'on
n'a pas de brûlures ensuite une issue
merci ça se boit tout seule commande
pour faire attention merci beaucoup
madeleine tenter un plaisir
[Musique]